tiere schrumpfen durch den klimawandel
und auch die riesigen zug vogelschwärme
sind von der weltweiten erwärmung
betroffen milliarden vögel machen sich
im herbst auf dem weg nach afrika um
dort den winter zu verbringen
doch sie müssen immer weiter fliegen bis
zu 1000 kilometer alle spannenden infos
dazu jetzt bei klicks thoms 1 in future
gibt es dreimal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts
[Musik]
herzlich willkommen
dieses video ist in kooperation mit der
cd fotografie entstanden dem fachmagazin
rund um digitale bilder und am ende oder
schon hier und emmi erwartet euch ein
exemplar kostenlos und durch die
unterstützung von ct fotografie ist
dieses video auch komplett werbefrei wer
schon mal interessiert ist klickt
einfach auf eine reise von tausenden
kilometern mehr als 18.000 kilometer
sind es zum teil
die riesige vogelschwärme zwischen ihrem
nördlichen brutgebieten und den wärmeren
regionen zum überwintern zurücklegen
genau jetzt ist die große zeit der
kraniche und gänse zwischen september
und anfang dezember versammeln sich die
vögel anbauen und mooren aber auch in
küstengebieten und feuchtwiesen kann man
sie entdecken meist gegen ende november
anfang dezember starten sie dann von
diesen rastplätzen los zu ihrer großen
reise in riesigen schwärmen machen sich
die meisten von ihnen auf dem weg in
richtung süden und das sind wirklich
beeindruckende momente die auch anfänger
fotografinnen und fotografen
eindrucksvolle aufnahmen bescheren
können und große fliegende vogelschwärme
über landschaften zu fotografieren das
ist einfacher als man vielleicht denkt
doch um auch an kraniche und gänse zu
kommen die auf feldern wiesen und
naturschutzgebieten nach nahrung suchen
da habe ich am ende des videos ein paar
tipps für fotografinnen und fotografen
die zugvögel haben uns gerade nicht
einfach der klimawandel macht den tieren
das leben schwer
unter anderem lässt die erderwärmung die
tiere schrumpfen das hat eine studie aus
dem vergangenen jahr 2009 10 gezeigt ein
us museum hat er bereits in den 70er
jahren damit begonnen
tote zugvögel einzusammeln und zu
vermessen damals war der begriff des
klimawandels vielleicht gerade weil
einigen fachleuten bekannt mittlerweile
sind es 70 tausend tiere von 52
verschiedenen arten die das field museum
in chicago seit dem katalog
visiert hat diese sammlung ist
einzigartig und sie zeigt jetzt wie sehr
die erderwärmung tiere verändern kann
im laufe der vergangenen 40 jahre sind
die zugfolge kleiner geworden um zwar um
2,4 im selben zeitraum vergrößerten sich
dagegen die flügel der tiere und zwar um
1,3 prozent wie das forschungsteam in
seiner studie schreibt die
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
verweisen auf die sogenannte bergmann
schregel demnach haben sich in wärmeren
regionen vor allem spezies entwickelt
deren körperbau im verhältnis zu ihrem
volumen eine große oberfläche aufweist
in kälteren teilen der erde leben der
tiere die groß und kompakt sind wenn
vögel also kleiner werden und die
spannweite der flügel größer können sie
ihre körper bei hitze besser
herunterkühlen
denn mehr wärme kann dann abgegeben
werden auch andere tiere scheinen wegen
der erderwärmung zu schrumpfen wie
andere studien bereits nahe legen mit
dabei unter anderem salamander und
ziegen und die evolution ist da
unerbittlich wir haben ja hier einen
ähnlichen fall wie bei den elefanten in
afrika über dem meer berichtet hatten
bei denen immer mehr elefanten ohne
stoßzähne geboren werden der einfache
grund elefanten mit stoßzähnen werden
von wilderern getötet so können nur die
ohne stoßzähne nachwuchs zeugen die
stoßzähne verschwinden bei den vögeln
oder anderen tieren überleben die tiere
mit der nicht so guten anpassung an den
klimawandel nicht so lange so dass sie
nachwuchs zeugen könnten tiere die
besser angepasst sind überleben und
bekommen nachwuchs andere körpergrößen
und flügel dimensionen setzten sich
durch die evolution agiert da im
wahrsten sinne des wortes ohne rücksicht
auf verluste
und das extrem schnell wenn es sein muss
doch der klimawandel hat noch weitere
auswirkungen aufzug für gewinnt
verschiedene wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler zeigen konnten vor
kurzem hatte ein internationales
forschungsteam herausgefunden dass vor
allem zugvögel die bereits heutzutage
lange unterwegs sind in zukunft noch
länger reisen müssen das sind vor allem
die tiere die auf grund des insekten
schwundes im sommer und winter wegen des
mangelnden futters zu leiden haben die
forschenden nehmen den bienenfresser als
beispiel diese vogelart die vor allem in
den südlichen alpen zu hause ist wird
demnach in den kommenden fünf
jahrzehnten knapp 1000 kilometer weiter
fliegen müssen
auf dieser langen reise wird dann eine
zusätzliche pause nötig sein so dass die
tiere vier tage länger unterwegs sein
werden doch fest steht
je länger die zugvögel unterwegs sind um
so mehr gefahren sind sie ausgesetzt
es sind nicht nur fressfeinde sondern
auch wetterumschwünge und menschen die
sie bedrohen langstreckenflüge werden
von den vögeln uhr bewältigt werden
genügend futter zur verfügung steht und
auch das ist in unbekanntem gebiet nicht
immer gewährleistet doch an ihren
rastplätzen ist es für die vögel nicht
nur wichtig nach futter zu suchen und
ihre energiereserven aufzufüllen sondern
eine verlängerte reisedauer erhöht zudem
auch das risiko dass die tiere zu spät
im brutgebiet ankommen klar ist auch
dass potenzielle rastplätze durch den
klimawandel verlorengehen küstennahe
lebensräume vivat gebiete werden durch
den anstieg des meeresspiegels abnehmen
apropos küstengebiete noch sind diese
die hotspots überhaupt für zahlreiche
vogelarten kein wunder bei dem
reichhaltigen nahrungsangebot im
wattenmeer der nordsee beispielsweise
stärken sich viele vögel für ihre
anstrengende reise anzutreffen sind hier
nicht nur gänse und ausland fischer
sondern auch riesige mückenschwärme aber
auch die kulisse an der nordseeküste mit
ihrem monotonen farbtönen der dünnen und
strände zieht fotografie begeisterte an
leuchttürme deiche und windkrafträder
ragen aus der flachen küstenlandschaft
hervor und charakterisieren diese region
die meisten rastplätze der großen zug
funkel sperre sind in
naturschutzgebieten zu finden
doch hier ist der zutritt zum schutz der
tiere verboten dennoch gibt es auch hier
hofft möglichkeiten fotos zu machen denn
behörden lokale landschafts
fördervereine und naturschutzverbände
betreuen die naturschutzgebiete
gemeinsam und bieten beispielsweise
touren an manchmal werden auch fade für
besucherinnen und besucher angelegt und
vor ort aussichtstürme aufgestellt also
ich kann das wirklich nur empfehlen
das sind wirklich atemberaubende
eindrücke die man da sammelt selbst wenn
man nicht fotografiert auch so kann man
als fotograf von fotografen auf seine
kosten kommen bei manchen vogelstation
ist es auch möglich kleine unterstände
für einen tag anzumieten
diese befinden sich direkt an den
futterplätzen der vögel als fotograf
oder fotografen muss man sich dann
bereits vor der ankunft der vögel da
breit machen und ausharren bis die tiere
wieder abfliegen mit maiskörnern lassen
sich kraniche beispielsweise dann ganz
nah vor den unterstand locken eine ganz
besondere begegnung denn die
fluchtdistanz von kranichen beträgt etwa
300 meter das ist natürlich eine ganz
besondere
aufforderung doch neben dem herbst gibt
es einen weiteren zeitraum im jahr also
wenn er es jetzt nicht mehr schafft um
sich in der zugvogel fotografie zum
probieren anfang frühling im märz und
april nämlich sind es die weißstörche
die aus ihrem winterquartier zurück nach
deutschland kommen sie nisten dann
manchmal mitten in dörfern und städten
auf gebäuden oder masten und lassen sich
so ganz besonders gut fotografieren bis
august ziehen sie dann ihren nachwuchs
auf doch nicht mal darauf braucht man
unbedingt zu warten wenn man auf der
suche nach eindrucksvollen
vogelschwärmen zum fotografieren ist
klar ist um zugvögel zu fotografieren
braucht es kein profi equipment auch mit
einer normalen fotoausrüstung lassen
sich tolle fotos von zugvögeln machen
wichtig sind die kameraeinstellungen zum
einen natürlich die situation dass sich
die vögel in größerer entfernung oder
entspannen auf rast oder futterplätzen
aufhalten
der tipp bei vielen fliegenden vögeln
verhältnismäßig viele aufnahmen zu
machen denn dann sollte die trefferquote
hoch sein und eine scharfe aufnahme
dabei sein
die kamera wird dem motiv nach geführt
und fotografiert wird mit serien
belichtung den autofokus dabei auf
kontinuität einstellen damit die kamera
während der serien belichtung für jedes
bild neu fokussiert befinden sich die
zug für gibt dagegen auf feldern oder
wiesen sollte man am besten mit der
kamera auf ein stativ aufnehmen zugvögel
lassen sich am besten mit systemkameras
und teleobjektiven fotografieren denn
für weitwinkelobjektive ja da sind die
vögel fast immer zu weit entfernt und
werden dann nur kleine punkte
empfehlenswert sind tele sohnes mit rund
70 bis 300 millimetern brennweite
sie eignen sich besonders wenn aus allen
richtungen immer wieder vogelschwärme
aufsteigen und vorbeiziehen
zoomobjektive sind vorteilhaft man
verschiedene brennweiten ohne
objektivwechsel eingestellt werden
können zum schluss noch ein paar tipps
für alle die keine professionelle kamera
haben und auf ihr smartphone setzen ein
problem hierbei ist die weitwinkel
brennweite die die aufnahme von
zugvögeln nicht ermöglicht doch um die
effektive brennweite zu verlängern lohnt
sich der einsatz von tele vorsätzen
smartphones haben keine bayonetta oder
gewinde
dennoch können sie vor dem objektiv
positioniert werden und zwar mit hilfe
von speziellen haltern oder klemmen
ein us-amerikanischer hersteller bietet
sogar hüllen für verschiedene
smartphones und einige optische vorsätze
in guter qualität an zu können zugvögel
dann auch mit hilfe von smartphones vor
oft werden wichtig wie immer bei der
tierfotografie eine gute vorbereitung wo
sind die beobachtungs plätze spielt das
wetter mit und wann sind die besten
zeiten vor ort zu sein wichtig sind
außerdem die entsprechende kleidung
sonnencreme wenn es die sonne vom himmel
brennt das kann auch im winter der fall
sein und insektenschutz naja das ist im
moment nicht so akut dann aber im
frühjahr wieder das video ist in der
zusammenarbeit mit der ct fotografie
entstanden und als klicks um zu schauen
dann bekommt ihr jetzt sogar eine
digitale ausgabe gratis mit vielen
profitipps fundierten workshops und
spannenden how to anleitung außerdem
findet ihr dank der umfangreichen
produkttests von kameras objektive und
fotozubehör auf jeden fall das richtige
equipment probiert es aus es kostet
nichts alles was er dafür tun muss ist
sie auf diesen link zu klicken oder die
aktion über die video beschreibung
aufzurufen also bis dann bleibt dran